what is this protein proteins
smile Countless organelles in the world take part in
transporting some nutrients in the body
some chemicals or make it
happen quickly and some of them
form the structure of living
things besides these inputs all proteins are the
same 21 but we want it
but if it shows it consists of carbon oxygen nitrogen
hydrogen sweep the throats
can pass Selin system contains Selenium
is hardly a fight for you batons make
three rates talk one group group group
All
depends on loss of a Center
this night vodka Monastery Cargo has rich variable groups this night vodka Monastery Cargo
does
not enter water iteration they
can enter as hydrophilic price  tests can counter-
charge or
react with other molecules protein structure
a structure a protein first gate
used by Berna
consists of adjacent amino acids make up the
protein show they are
linked by peptide bonds  A bonded peptide bond is formed between the
carboxyl group of one mother and the other mother to the
me group.
At the end of each bond, a cold molecule is released. This
series of carbon, hydrogen and oxygen atoms forms the protein backbone,
these chains usually form two different
second pockets. These are referred to as alphalic and
beta-pak.  Moon Felix
is a helix with a structural assembly and the number of hydrogen bonds between amine
and carboxy groups close to each other is fo
med. Beta morning apricot is fo
me
by the establishment of hydrogen bonds between two adjacent chains. A protein 3rd s
ructure is the t
ree-dimensional shape of prote
n chain
.  Many proteins form spherical shapes
and
keep the hydrophobic chains inside in a way that does not come into contact,
while proteins attached to the cell membrane are intertwined with the hydrophobic part
membrane. Thus
, the fats on the body can be traction.
These Facebook
these charged proteins
can interact with ashes that have counter-Turks
[Music]
Protein Fox functions are
based on their three dimensional For example,
why protein has 15 in its center and a pocket to carry
a small molecule with oxygen around
it Fourth
Structure Two or more polypeptide
chains  461 of the problem that a functional molecule made up of different
units can come together and
work together This
mechanism ensures that the formed complex can
easily hold oxygen in the lungs and
then how to get its power. These
proteins give visual clues to our different visual
representatives about the protein structure and
function.
In the program
, we can see the organization of the protein backbone and the
Alpine surface representation, and
then
we can use the ashes to see the obvious beauty. The
size of proteins and a half protein
is smaller than the wavelength of light.  As
a matter of fact, hemoglobin is a protein found in red blood cells, about six and a half kilometers long
. In a classical
red blood cell,
there are close to 280 million. These
three-dimensional structures of the AK Party
determine their functions.
Let's take a look at them now, let's take a look at them, defense antibodies,
antibodies can play arms,
detect pathogens and bind to them.
These pathogens direct the defense system. Thus, it
protects us from diseases. There is a
lot of this communication. Insulin hormone is a small and
stable protein and can start to
form the city even in its movement in the
blood. Thus,
it helps to maintain the blood sugar level. Enzymes iPhone Milas
Milas Salih Usta found I work
patients who can digest download
and transport  Kayseri pumps calcium
pumps work without adjusting magnesium and using ATP It
is a copy that takes back muscle ions after everyone joins the society
sarcoplasmic You can see in Gebze Kocaeli
active a dynamic protein warehouse  but the storm is a
spherical protein that contains channels that allow iron atoms to enter and
exit.
This Iron can
be met according to the needs of the organism
in which
it is found.  they
have sepia of three and provide structural support throughout the body
. The molecules I will put in can
form the idea of long These becom
collagen films These go-to colle
es are located in the skin and tendons these are located in the skin and tendons To learn more
bout the functions of these proteins and other molecular structures visit Recep
e dot org s
te  You can check out
other structural voluntary content on our channel.
Thank you for listening. We wish you a good day
.
Subscribe subscribe.